[Music]
deer creek international business
solutions how can i help you i am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh i see what
you're doing ladybug's supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck
really
my bad luck is biblical i'm not even
trying to kill people and someone dies i
remember the suicidal bell boy you drove
him to the hospital hang in there buddy
and he didn't die okay the wedding
tequila
johannesburg
it's time for some change do you want it
simple for your first job back it
doesn't get simpler
we need to find the person who took that
case
that's too easy
what remember those two wackos from
the bolivia job the twins yeah and i'm
so sure they're twins get off the train
you stab me
i will never stop coming for you what
i missed my stop something else going on
here hi
you don't remember me you look like
every white homeless man i've ever seen
really you don't remember me
oops he's a pack of dicks lady i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm i'm working on it
get off at the next stop sounds so easy
when you say it one little prick from
this you know what happens yes your
blood congeals
i said yes
ah
boss you're going to want to hear
the whole story what's waiting for us in
kyoto the white death with his army of
assassins there's this solar psychotic
leader with the largest criminal
organization on the planet shoved right
inside off
i don't see the white death letting any
of us off this train
we need to come up with a plan
what's happening to your face maybe
there was a little head trauma
[Music]
i i got to get off this train
sorry buddy
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
you